What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
Today we will play glow in the dark ping pong
This is by far the most requested thing on our channel to do
So we are finally doing it!
We have bought a few UV lamps
And then we got tapes
We don't know if this works at all
But we are going to try it out!
This is so exciting to try something like this
I'm really looking forward to seeing how this will look!
So we have the table ready
Emil, lights!
Oh yeah! This looks cool!
Wow!
This is way better than I ever imagined it to be!
It's time to give Emil some make up
I seriously think the face paint is a bad idea
There we have
Emil's war painting
Looking good!
Paint me beautiful
Don't paint my hair
How much are you putting?
Emptying the whole bottle on my face!
I'll paint Otto eyebrows
That didn't work very well...
This looks great
I like those!
And then something on the nose as well
Otto looks like a mouse!
I need to put whiskers!
He looks like a cat!
So we are making ourselves glow in the dark
That's so good
We need more of this
This sticks a bit better on my hands than Otto's hands!
I wonder why
Do I look like a stick figure?
This looks just like a movie!
I mean, it's way too good to be true!
I think we should tape Otto's beard
I don't think so!
I think we are ready to start!
You actually can play surprisingly well here
Yeah, I'm surprised
Almost!
Victory dance!
Guys if you wanna see more crazy videos like this
Do consider hitting subscribe!
Okay maybe it's time to stop this!
It's clearly 5 AM!
Okay I think this was one of the coolest things we have ever done on our channel!
Yeah
And if you guys enjoyed it as much as we did
Remember to go and hit subscribe!
Also, leave a like if you want to see a part 2!
Until next time!